Eric Stonestreet your your co-star
pranks you constantly yes all the time
and he this is actually I think you took
a picture of this he did this to your
car on the lot that would say about you
if you really did that I drove home with
that on my car drove home with that nice
car and so the next day I I put
something on his car it wasn't really
that much of an insult he was happy with
it okay oh my god wow you really got it
yeah exactly he drove around with that
for five days what I didn't see it you
enjoy a good guys boat in a filthy car
yeah we were we're on a ride it's over
nobody I've used we run a little case
that was very dusty you enjoy a good
prank you like to photobomb when you're
on a red carpet any event where there
are celebrities around it's not even
that I like doing it it's just I can't
help myself
yeah I just I see the opportunity I'm
like I got to do this since like my body
takes over and I'm doing something
ridiculous I feel like they're gonna ask
me to stop coming to red carpet event
well here's Miranda Kerr on the she's
out there and you're guessing that's the
Vanity Fair sorry
and amanda peet I think is there with
our awards with their husband
that's me don't know a Broadway I bring
a little Broadway to the right Sarah
Paulson of course right you got some
good elevators in there all these people
I know and like I I'm friendly with them
so I was like okay they won't be too mad
about it yeah but I always get very
nervous like right before you like what
if I knocked them over and then there's
that moment yeah that would get a lot of
pickup that's why I keep doing it hope
is there a publicist that would be my
only advice go knock them over to get
some play
you